oh he's crying I'm not feeling good  right now I'm not looking forward to  this this will be a first I'm a little  concerned I think it's gonna hurt a lot  trying to find the thickest one I can  find the thickest one alright this is  really weird  oh [ __ ] that's a big head  that was in my nose what the [ __ ] ah hey  not really right hand yeah yeah let's do  early cheering up let's not do that  anymore could we do it again no not  really no no yeah it's a lot variable  it's fine if you want to make yourself  cry do it but no that's the worst thing  ever I don't know why people would do  that at all I'm sorry I'm sorry I put  you there it is  you look so much prettier yeah yeah  absolutely the girls they don't like it  yeah